sonny gray lark coming off
an outstanding outing 11 strikeouts
nearly went
six against the dodgers his numbers from
western and southern
yeah sunny needs to be the stopper for
these this team today
gray into his wind up as he brings it
home to nick madrigal
weird carom barehand play for india nice
job by the rookie
a little assist from sonny gray on the
kick right there and
india understanding he didn't have time
to go to the glove
made a nice bare hand play and the throw
on the run
athleticism now johan monkatta
shift on grounded sharply backhand
diving smother bottle shovel how do you
get it off
and sonny gray on the cover oh the
infield turning tricks
and vado loves it so dallas kykel the
starting pitcher for the sox today and
you see the left-handed average that is
not typical for his career his career
average against lefties 230.
so you would imagine those splits would
reverse themselves at some point and he
does have four lefties to deal with
today
payoff downstairs and zell walks
jesse winker a left-handed bat do up
broken bat little flare fair ball
zedzelle
storms through second garcia gathers it
right stop sign at third
and jesse winker broken bad
duble down the right field line
now joey bottom ground ball to first
dabra steps on the bag the throw to the
plate
is out but did he step on the bag at
first did he
get the bag before he uncorked the throw
to the plate
i think they said he did and yes they're
gonna call it a double play
we'll get the replay from cincinnati at
some point down the line here
he never stepped on the back yeah i
think they're going to challenge
that
[Music]
now the white sox threw the ball back to
first
so the other question is did vado did he
ever get there
get to first base let's watch vato did
he ever get to first base
he did yes clearly okay so that'll be
end up being a fielder's choice for vato
they will i believe overturn this
double play now in order and the batter
is suarez
there's the ground ball they get one
two inning over
now there's two on with one out and the
batter is larry garcia
swinging a miss first k for sonny greg
now billy hamilton swinging it a miss
the high heat
mcgray overwhelms hamilton and back to
back k
strand of hair here's naquin the right
fielder and for castillanos
hey there's another little lazy ground
ball
reds go in order here's tim anderson
there's tim to right field we've seen
that a lot base hit
first hit for the sox today is to the
10th batter
and now with two outs here's johan
manchada hard ground ball big
bound nice adjustment from india makes
the play
jonathan indy has been tested on three
challenging plays he's made a ball
leadoff man nick senzelle steps in for
his second trip grounded to anderson
it's short couple steps over to his left
over to
brayu 6-3 on the out another one two
three inning
for dallas kykel the sox come to bad in
the fourth with jose
abreu to lead things off swing at a miss
the high
fastball from sonny gray his third
strikeout
the one-two pitch devaughn breaking ball
down and away
but he could not check he went around
and back-to-back strikeout for sonny
gray
two down heavy shift for yasmani grandal
and there's the fastball strike
lower third tight grandal disagrees
gray strikes out the side here's joey
votto
weigh in motto says it got him
appeal says no check swing nevada hit by
pitch now a walk
and the reds have two on with one out
and here's mike mustakas
one and two lined hard to first defray
who's on it
and duck suarez two down jose with his
head
up looking for that third out of the
inning he was hunting it but it was
nowhere to be found
suarez like please do not throw this
ball
two down for stevenson first base side
jose backpedaling for route number three
back to work for the reds he goes to
work here
against laurie garcia there's another
weak wave and a miss by garcia
and that's four straight strikeouts for
sonny gray
the one two to kykel st right three
right over the outside corner that's
seven punch-outs now
is getting it together for sonny gray so
kykel now working with a man on
bounce to third second one
they go around the horn that's a double
play
two down joey votto hit by pitch in the
fourth inning on the thumb
is now out kyle farmer is in moncada was
robbed by jonathan india
last time up nicely framed strike three
this is just a great pitch from sonny
gray we saw the fastball in the inner
half
and then the backdoor breaking ball the
batter is jose abreu's 0 for 2 against
gray today
suarez outfield grass short way
the inning 80 pitches to breeze through
six
stellar endings sunny gray's longest
outing of the year
farmer walks comes suarez
that is going to be caught by vaughn so
kykel puts up another scoreless frame
we'll head to the top of the seventh
here's leori garcia
grounded in india late break to his left
sliding stop one play snaps into first
in time
excellent recovery and recognition by
india
he's playing second base as if he's been
there his entire life
great instinct over there here's
hamilton hamilton ground ball back to
gray
oh he's an athlete too in the former
high school qb
beats hamilton to the bag on the toss
sonny gray
sensational tyler stevenson in now he's
out for two today
he's struck him out that is a dandy of a
changeup lin
first strikeout chance to get through
seven for the first time this season
third consecutive start in which he's
gone at least
six on the ground first base side
abreu's got it and he taps the bag
sprawling out to make the play that is a
heck of a play
well gray is done seven scoreless two
hits
90 pitches he struck out eight new
pitcher is tj antone
now nick madrigal grounded mustache
a dominant one two three inning for t.j
antone
scoreless still mid-eighth so michael
kopeck out of the bullpen and kopek
has been virtually unhittable 3-2
fastball busted him high and tight at
98.
and the reds have two on with two out
back-to-back two-out walks in the eighth
farmer goes up top to pop it up
madrigal and anderson and it's tim
making the catch in a freeze
for out number three no score after
eight
one on one out and now andrew vaughn
grounded up the middle india hits the
bag it's been his day defensively
4-3 dp a minimum face-deading
alex blandino hits in the pitcher spot
to right center down base hit
lost on a bare hand try by garcia
steaming the second blandino
slides in legging out scoring position
they're gonna put it on the back of the
rookie jonathan indian runners go
payoff misses a walk to load the bases
i think it's uh hendricks time and
that's what tony
is going to do so bases loaded two outs
ninth inning
tie game hendricks to barnhart ground
ball to third
will go to the 10th sox nothing reds
nothing after nine interesting call here
you have layori garcia
who's tried to bunt a couple times this
year and has not done well with
it jam job ground ball mustache second
india on the first safe and they get the
force at second hendricks gets third
swag into this
sims can celebrate with the fist pump he
whiffs hamilton
and strands hendricks 90 feet away no
score
bottom 10 top of the order due up for
the reds
that's over short that gets down base
hit
lamb a late sub comes up throwing in
barnhart held at third
and the reds have the winning run 90
feet away
with nobody out on a nick senzelle base
not
here's jesse winker
payoff smoke to centerfield the reds
win well john i don't know
what else to say wink has just been
incredibly clutch for this team
aggressive
great at bat stayed off of a
nice breaking ball down in the dirt
[Music]
he can hit a fastball oh yeah
gotta run